ils vivent parfois au bord des routes
nationales pas forcément en moins de
palme mais toujours loin de ceux qui les
dirigent leur vie ressemble assez peu à
ce qu'on voit à la télé ils ont le
sentiment d'être des français de seconde
zone comme s'ils étaient invisibles ces
français ne veulent plus tard ils ont
des choses à dire la france oubliée
c'est une rencontre avec ces citoyens
qui ne se résignent pas à la fatalité la
france oubliée c'est montrer ce qu'on ne
voit jamais
aujourd'hui je me rends à la capelle
dans une maison familiale rurale ou des
jeunes en difficulté sont scolarisés
j'y retrouve vanessa bonjour vanessa un
jour tu as quel âge lorsque j'avais 19
ans on est où ici ou là on est dans un
format de la mfs balle alors que je suis
actuellement scolarisés depuis ma 4e là
je suis en première bac pro vente
alimentaire les semaines où je ne suis
pas ici je suis en
l'entreprise mais vu que ma
problématique c'est que j'en ai poche en
pleine recherche de tu trouves pas de
stage et finalement si tu as peur
aujourd'hui ton stage bâton l'année elle
est cuite wallace et gromit jusqu'à fin
février puisque enfin loyer passage et
j'ai rien de ça se casse mais ça me fait
un peu mal au coeur quand ça va partir
comme ça en pleine année scolaire
ça fait un peu mal au coeur c'est super
cool c'est tout neuf quoi un baby ses
coûts c'est un peu ta seconde main sans
cesse à donc elle s'occupe de quoi ici
c'est la directrice ccs et la directrice
photo finish conte et du tourisme en
comblant gauche
ah ouais tu peux faire des visites
guidées maintenant donc c'est là oui
enfin
bonjour bonjour bonjour bienvenue à la
maison familiale
merci ça fonctionne comment alors c'est
un internat qui dépend du ministère de
l'agriculture c'est ça voilà l'objectif
c'est d'accueillir des jeunes qui sont
souvent ici ou en mal être par rapport à
une situation scolaire qu'ils ont connue
dans le système classique
il arrive en 4ème l'avantagent c'est
surtout de de se remettre bien avec
l'école par l'intermédiaire des stages à
la us once et ap et de là elle s'est dit
moi je veux poursuivre sur un bac avec
l'obligation bien entendu cette fois-ci
de trouver un contrat d'apprentissage et
là c'est un peu le parcours du
combattant s'il ya le dire et là avec
l'attrait du coc vite ça n'arrange pas
les choses
du coup ça veut que nous les jeunes nous
ont pas ton chien patron il m'a dit
c'est pas que je ne veux pas de prendre
les si je peux pas te payer correctement
c'est pas la peine on cherche on
recherche on lâche rien on va y arriver
tu te vois dans quoi plus tard tu te
projettes un petit peu moi je prends
tout ce qui est un peu sous la main le
jeu pas vraiment de métier en tête je
veux pour moi un travail à son travail
j'ai beaucoup de respect pour tous les
métiers qui existent donc
pourquoi pas aussi si ça marche pas dans
la vente pourquoi pas sega notre métier
par les entrées aux personnes qui peut
d'une part me faire confiance et puis
notre part mme dire ouais les inconnus
on est toujours sortir sans délai
c'est toujours match parce qu'elle
voulait madame un sens oui ça vaut le
coup de faire ce métier là ce que vous
faites
parce que là vous voyez les résultats
concrets bien entendu que ça vaut le
coup parce qu'on peut pas faire ce
métier là aussi on aime pas déjà nos
jeunes si on n'aime pas les jeunes en
général
la problématique c'est que c'est très
difficile quand on est jeune d'aller
chercher un stage
aujourd'hui mon dilemme il est un peu il
faut absolument qu'on arrive à trouver
une solution là d'ici un mois
et ça ça me fait un peu le coeur parce
que ses contacts personnels pour tous
voilà oui bonjour bonjour la nsa tu veux
tu installé
c'est vanessa l'acteur principal alors
comme on disait si tu veux ce matin un
tu veux aller un petit peu sur sur la
connaissance de de la ville d'hirson
pour voir un petit peu toutes les
entreprises 1 qui existent pas bon pour
eux tu vas sur mon père est d'accord je
reviens vers toi donc là quand même tu
viens parfois de malades et des amis ont
mal à carrefour et puis on est en plein
doute un petit peu ça nous permettrait
de passer un peu de temps et ils
seraient fallait qu'on soit rentré
absolument pour mieux c'est beau la
parce que toi ça serait peut-être plus
facile détendre ta recherche
un peu plus loin si tu avais justement
l'occasion de bouger ça joue beaucoup
puisque moi vous cuisinez quoi moi moyen
de locomotion et je fais tous mes
trajets
à un pied ça fait comment je suis con
c'est par rapport à ça comment ça se
fait que tu as pas de scooter
rien que le code ça coûtait ça coûte
assez cher et quand on est dans ma
situation son contrat soit rien on ne
peut pas pas vraiment le payer et puis
moi disons plutôt que je viens d'une
famille assez nombreuses j'ai pas non
plus envie que ma mère dépose les mêlées
décembre dans sa bourse et c'est dommage
pour moi mais elle fait déjà tout ce
qu'elle peut pour déjà pour nous payer
l'école et pour nous payer au moins
nécessaire pour qu'on puisse à oman -
s'habiller se laver manger tout ça c'est
une famille nombreuse
j'ai quatre seraient trop frère au total
ah oui d'accord
donc c'est vrai que ça fait un peu
grande famille j'ai les deux soeurs qui
me font que fait la maison j'ai mon
grand frère je pourrais il est à la
maison mais pour moi j'ai l'impression
qu'ils cherchent pas vraiment s'en
sortir en fait il a quel âge 25 ans
c'est plus une charge en plus pour ma
mère parce qu'elle nous paye des trucs
aussi écrit nuit s'il cherche pas
vraiment
boulot dit quoi quand tu dis mais
cherche un boulot est souvent dit ouais
toute façon à rien il ya personne qui
prend la route où s'achevait en même
temps tu cherches pas ces mêmes
il faut peut-être plusieurs chances si
tu veux trouver quelque chose dans ma
famille on a tous un fort caractère on
est tous vraiment buté sur quelque chose
et dès qu'on a quelque chose à la télé
ça finit souvent dans un gala de boxe et
vanille cela on finit toujours la
séquence l'émission par une photo donc
tu vas tu vas te mettre là tu va pousser
les murs parfait
[Musique]